[Music]
i'm sure that you guys have a ping pong
table that's there and people in the
cast crew competitions they come to you
guys play here at all because we compete
against other shows just saying okay
again i've made it clear to everyone
here on my show if anyone enjoys
themselves with ping pong they're fired
yeah
i'm like stalin you can tell who's here
yeah
are you enjoying yourself yeah it's a
great work environment no we play a lot
of ping-pong and we have massive
competitions how and now are you a
competitive person yes
i don't like to lose right i don't like
i will do anything to win i there was
like some people would say that i did a
little cheating
i would say i didn't how do you cheat in
ping-pong well i would at the time this
is a few years ago i would go put on the
tiniest outfit known to mankind
come down and i would just play i don't
see why that's cheating right and then
you know i do things like oh i've got to
go grab this ball and they go no we we
have the ball and i go oh i gotta clean
the floor and like you know i was always
kind of
and i won every time yeah
i don't know why and all these guys
wanted to play it was weird
they didn't even care if they lost shows
yeah drivers it was weird they didn't
even have a paddle
they should have they should have tried
to find a gay ringer yeah yeah well i
would have found a
way uh wow well i actually we uh i
looked around i found uh someone from
the show provided us with a photograph
of you in your ping pong outfit really
yeah let's take a look there you are
fantastic
i so did not wear that
what did you do but it was sort of like
that it wasn't really like that where
did i get it
where did i get that
it's called the internet oh okay
oh my god yeah that was um my wife my
wife was saying what are you doing it's
for the show
what
that's something for the show kaylee's
coming on
get out of my little room
yeah that face is a turn off
[Music]
now uh well now someone told me you were
i don't know before you're from are you
a are you a good driver you're a
terrible driver
no i'm not a good driver you're like a
very bad driver yeah i'm not a great
driver i think i told you this last time
remember i almost hit your car and we
were driving through security yes yeah
that's why i was thinking i was thinking
i remember it it was like in my reptile
brain i'm thinking i remember you almost
killing me once
we were going yeah i'm not the best
driver i admit it i'm openly oh i'm open
to it i know that i'm not great people
tell him tell me i'm not great um i
almost hit you driving in one day it's
just you know it's just part of me right
you don't but you just you stay to cars
though you don't you don't like uh like
ride bicycles or motorcycles no but i
totally want to get a motorcycle license
no you should see if you're bad at
driving a thing no don't get a
motorcycle license i know no one's
promoting this idea for me but um i just
think it'd be so cool i see the people
on the motorcycles and their signals
they're always like
what does that mean oh they're on meth
oh yeah
those aren't signals
it's ticks
man i can explain what's going on out
there
yeah i'm pretty street you are
wild
um i want to congratulate you you know
you've made it in this business when you
have your own bobble head oh my god your
own bobble head just came out you
haven't seen this yet
oh my god there you are
this is you on that
the only
guy she looks exactly like no uh uh
that's got to be exciting for you yeah i
mean obviously it looks exactly like me
i mean the only thing we have in common
is the constant movement of my head yeah
oh my god
totally you know yeah
uh it's great it's really great i guess
i've made it you have made it i mean
that's pretty cool i was excited when i
got my bobble head it's not it's pretty
much it's similar to yours
not to take any air out of your tires
but can we bring out my bobble head
please
[Applause]
put yours right there
there's yours
and then
there's mine
now really congratulations though thank
you you've got to be thrilled oh yeah
yeah where can i get one of those uh i'm
gonna get you one trust me yeah